yo yo mama so fat 32 she can't even
store files over four gigabytes and
she's so ugly she makes ssds turn floppy
if you don't get that joke you best
recognize that a file system is mostly
just a lookup table that keeps track of
where files are stored on a disk in the
early days we had the file allocation
table or fat but it was too small and
didn't support permissions it was
upgraded to FAT32 which is commonly used
on USB flash drives today but now we
also have xvat to support even larger
drives Windows has its own file system
called new technology file system while
Mac OS has the Apple file system while
Linux has the fourth extended file
system or ext4 all of which support
journaling encryption and other Advanced
features and now you can file this
useless information away in that file
system you call your brain